قبل اعوام بدات تهمه الاستفزاز تلاحق محمد
رمضان فمن ينسى تلك الصوره
الشهيره مع الكابتن الطيار الراحل اشرف
ابو اليسر الذي اقيل على اثرها من عمله
قبل ان يتوفى محمد رمضان كان على موعد مع
تهمه الاستفزاز مجددا بعد ذلك بسنوات حين
نزل الى شوارع الاسكندريه ردا على
الرافدين لاقامه حفله في المدينه ليتجول
فيها مؤكدا حبا اسلا ايضا كان الاستفزاز
مرافقا لتصرفات رمضان لا سيما في لحظات
استعراض سيارته الجديده وهو الامر الذي
عاده ما يكرره رمضان كلما اقتنى سياره
رمضان عرف بصوره الغريبه فمثلا ينظف
اسناننا بمعجون من الذهب كذلك فهو معروف
بنشر منشورات فيسبوكييه تتحدث عن شخصه
وكفاحه وانه لو عاد به الزمن لفعل نفس
الاشياء التي يفعلها دوما
وان تجاوز رمضان تهمه استفزاز الجمهور
فكيف يتجاوز تهمه استفزاز زملاء المهنه
خصوصا وانه دائما ما يقول انه النمبر وان
وهو الامر الذي يرفضه الوسط الفني عموما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات